et on se quitte avec un mot sur l'euro
2016 ce soir le portugal et la pologne
s'affrontent pour le premier match des
quarts de fil à des quarts de finale par
dont le vélodrome de marseille les
accueillera à 21h quaresma avait sauvé
son équipe face à la croatie la semaine
dernière les supporters portugais
résidant dans les vignes sont confiants
mais surtout impatient écouter les ils
ont répondu à patrick jacques de dixmude
à on a hâte de voir le match et on
espère qu'on va gagner un ça va être
serré mais c'est jouable
2 0 pour nous plus de ronaldo en
première mi-temps correspond au deuxième
parfait qu'on fait en confiance je pense
qu'on deux buts de charisme en but de
ronaldo photo